[Musique]
le cnam la région et le département ont
signé ce jeudi 27 avril une convention
de partenariat avec la société securitas
france une convention quadripartite qui
a pour but le recrutement de jeunes
réunionnais en tant qu'agent de sécurité
nous avons pris deux arrêtés au niveau
du dollar et non plus en fait
collaborateur pareil
concrètement suite en séries sécu est
agencé l'homme était exercé le métier
d'agent pas nos agences un partenariat
qui vient conforter la volonté d'une
plus grande cohérence des politiques
publiques afin de permettre aux
réunionnais d'être mieux accompagner
dans leurs projets de mobilité
7 cf partenariat est un des temps forts
de l'habitude d'armes nous en signe
régulièrement avec les entreprises ou
les centres de formation car c'est sur
eux que nous nous reposons pour former
accueillir des réunionnais qui veulent
aller en mobilité et puissamment une
société les jamie se déplace sur notre
département et qui viennent faire le
recrutement remplaçant c'est très
important pour nous mon iphone est
hongrois a été sautée de gerland
et peut-être demain lui revenir c'est la
nuit
suite à l'opération de recrutement qui
s'est déroulé du 24 au 27 avril 15
réunionnais ont été recrutés par
securitas
[Musique]